die sind überall gänge kommen die dir
bekannt vor die gänge die gänge sind
wirklich von die gänge sind nicht von
uns
servus s kids und auch an alle zuschauer
von logo ein herzliches willkommen zu
der neuen folge minecraft legend mit typ
und wir sind hochmotiviert denn unsere
fähigkeiten betriebstätigkeit von
metzler ist jetzt endlich verflogen ja
wir haben es geschafft und wir können
ein projekt sind dahin noch mal runter
bauen wir haben jetzt unsere backup
kiste dabei der mühle falls einer stirbt
wehe wenn dann was wir seit einfach so
viele leute und schreibe niemandem wohl
unserer backup ist hier unter natürliche
höhlen reingehen besser da einlasse
zurück zu unserer höhle dort ist ja auch
stark machen alles und nahm das kabel
ist schon abgefahren aber immer karotten
feld angefangen da können wir als trieb
eingänge machen wenn ihr eine karotten
der frage wo bist du eher hinten weiter
da ich ja schon mal gestorben bin weiß
jetzt wo es hingeht dass er mindestens
im vorteil
aha gut und lassen den wegpunkt weißt du
was kein gesetzt hast das sollte
eigentlich unser motto für die nächsten
folgen seien wir sollten einfach
versuchen oder hätte das motto für die
folgen sein sollen einfach im negativen
ins positive zu treten so wie du gerade
dann hätten wir einfach das hinbekommt
ja ich hab das erste dropmann den
crafting table mit damit hier keine
sprache finden wir bräuchten auch wenn
wir ein paar baumpilze hätten wir
optimum
hast du noch einen dabei aber ich kann
versuchen
ansonsten haben wir noch ein brot und
dann wieder nur so kennt aber das ist
schon mal unser kornfeld geht ja hier
geht es rein volk jetzt einfach ich
kenne in den weg die kohle fördern wir
eigentlich auch unten abfahren und ich
habe keine spitzer gewartet aber wir
haben doch genug holz hast du ja ich
habe da jetzt extra holz gefahren oder
über wechsel ja das kann ich dennoch
zeigen das wollte ich dann noch zwei
gute tage geben aber da wir waren hier
in dieser höhle quasi ich gestorben bin
hier hinten waren unsere kisten die sind
jetzt weg hier ist aber auch dort also
hier sind schon leute nochmal danke gang
noch mal danke krass die leute keine
kommentare schreiben wer das war aber so
auf interesse wirklich meint ja aber
nicht irgendwie was sie dort gemacht
erzählt aber schreibt uns einfach wäre
das war ich glaube unsere welt finden
die nicht mal gucken
man verehrt sich da unten so derb c't
leichten darüber weil wir ja tausende
von gang gegangen sind und wenn man sich
selbst orientieren können und leute ich
hatte einfach eine sache ansprechen
ich habe letztens einen kommentar
gelesen es war der einzige kommentar in
die richtung der gemeint hat ja an war
unter dem vorletzten video ist irgendwie
langweilig dieses farben und macht mehr
pvp dazu möchte ich sagen wir wollen uns
wirklich gut vorbereiten wir wollen
versuchen das projekt für euch zu
gewinnen und deswegen sind wir noch mal
unter die erde gegangen und bereiten
jetzt richtig gut vor mit entspannter
und alle masse finden damit wir dann für
euch die sache rocken können
und ja ich hoffe ihr versteht das da
laufe ich immer am anfang zu machen und
wir machen das nicht irgendwie so aus
weil wir keine lust am auto sondern weil
mein video wiederabstieg fast ist nicht
jedes mal ich mache aber ihr könnt
leider jetzt nicht besser machen weil
sie nämlich aufnehmen müssen aber jetzt
noch vor zu produzieren ich mache dann
einfach ich mache doch ich kann von
katar ist ein regal
dann sind meine folgen ein bisschen
kürzer als deine mutter nicht guck mal
bei meinen folgen war auch ein richtig
fettes problem über über die art
synchronität jetzt hier von was wir da
was da aus versehen passiert ist ja gut
zu herrn mit der nada verein und das
wird also ich warte hier oben auf dich
varianten geht es weiter und alles klar
bin ich bin aber rausgekickt worden naja
ich warte ich gehe noch mal zurück aus
klar
leider keine eine spitzhacke sonst
könnte ich mindestens kohle ab fahren
aber es ja kein ding ich warten ab ob
sie die entfällt da wo wir fahren wir
dann gehen wir auf missionen die ihr
hier
ich habe in meiner freizeit sehr viel
ware gespielt also den spielmodus und da
habe ich herausgefunden dass sie gar
nicht die optimale höhe für diamanten zu
zehn ist teilweise einfach echt mehr die
mehrheit gefunden als eisen in den in
den spielen rund bietet
ich hatte ja ja ich hatte vorhin gerade
eben schon zwei skelette
okay wir gehen jetzt einfach über den
arzt schon wieder kein es nervt mich
nicht mal getroffen egal wir können auch
eine karotten fällt natürlich mal
sprintet dann springst du die ganze zeit
oder ja hier ist übrigens der boxee fand
das will ich jetzt ausprobieren machen
den spieler ins rotbraune machen wir
jetzt eine spitzhacke das lasse ich nie
wieder auf mir sitzen da sie jetzt schon
15 kommentare bekommen habe den schatz
des wupsi fanden nicht gefunden sagen
gebt mir meine spitzhacke bauen wir uns
da jetzt rein ich will jetzt wissen wir
schlachten das ding jetzt für schlachten
ist okay wuxi wuxi kann man wolle mit
mit eine rolle kommt wolle kannst du
gleich mit der hand genau so schnell
abbauen mit der spitzhacke aber ihr
könnt euch jetzt hier raus vor betten
machen
es soll ein schatz muss sie fanden doch
haben sie mir geschrieben hatten dass
über einer der abbau hat mir das thema
der wupsi höchstpersönlich hat
geschrieben ist sollte einen schatz
geben
aber wo ihr baum unter dem schild ab das
ist korrekt ohne kann nicht wahr sein
ich finde nichts spieltag ist
aufgegangen kann neuer machen
dann lassen wir halten uns jetzt auch
noch höchstens ein paar minuten hier
drin auf
hin ist einen seite ist endlos viel rot
pilze also so unfassbar für roth willst
lass mal ich hab schon wieder die nase
voll von rohrenfels
ich hatte mal hier drüben der wupsi fand
guckt doch genau auf die andere seite
mit ganz großen augen war wo bestimmt
mein sonnenlicht extremis noch ein
höhlensystem und ob man dann wird mich
das jetzt nicht aber hier sind wir ja da
immer der ruf an guckt ja indirekt und
hörgenau erweckt sie was da warst du
dein geheimnis verraten was dein
geheimnis ist wir haben den schönen wir
haben die hornets pariert er sagt nichts
er schweigt richtig aber er hat in die
richtung geguckt okay also leute wissen
auf 416 dann macht schon mal spitz hat
man gehört hatte hatte ich mache vor
allem uns aber wieder 2 wassereimer da
die kleine schon mal beziehungsweise
erst mal könnt ihr jetzt keine speziali
kleiner stein spitzhacke noch wir müssen
ja außerdem ich runter ich wird jetzt
gleich in unsere base noch gehen
ich mache erst mal wasser einmal hier in
wassereimer und zumindest die einer sich
mal löschen kann natürlich wichtig sei
jetzt aber kommen jetzt lassen unsere
base kinder haben wir dann essen und
alles getan was wir brauchen und der
biester direkt natürlich nicht
nachgedacht
ja ich werde hier drüben die spitze
gehen liegt da oben bin ich jetzt nicht
mit vollen bonus von gibson schade für
die ganzen schafe die ihr dann
hierfür gelten haben ja weißt du noch
unser karotten feld ist ja wohl das
angefangen haben ja dann ist wollen die
richtung und ich bin der überzeugung
dass wir oben landen müssen
aber egal er lasse einfach weiterfahren
der laster wirklich runter gehen
vertrauen mir vertrauen mehr ein
einziges mal auch wenn ich schon so oft
scheiße gebaut habe
in sachen orientierung ist der logo
nicht schlecht in mein klarer das stimmt
in der newa wasser auch gut also wie
problems brauchen nur braun pilzen offen
nur gramm pilze wm 822 pilz aber
kein traumprinz du bist immer noch das
eisen mit hierfür werkzeuge richtig gut
kann ich schon eine spitzhacke haben
habe ich den stein spieltag nicht
gegeben lag habe ich davon hingeworfen
ja aber kommen wir denn jetzt bei der
base da können wir auch eisen zu machen
ging es für lanxess ja ja ich kann
nachvollziehen dass eine harte zeit hat
ist den weg zu finden wie die amis sagen
okay ich finde schon wieder neue diaz
wir sind jetzt leider ich glaube zwei
folgen hat sind zurück brown bild ihres
so bist du bei mir
das problem hat sich in luft aufgelöst
wir kennen viele braucht sie ja wir
können die anpflanzen
das ist besser aber komm gleich zurück
in jene space machen richtig gut alter
nehme auch noch das restliche eisen hier
wo bist du jetzt hier drüben hier die
enten in sneek mich kurz darum geht's ja
ja hinten geht's lang naja aber das gute
ist wirklich dadurch einmal um den kenne
ich jetzt ungefähr den weg an die spitze
zaubern schon auf den sommer braun pilz
zauberte mit spitzhacke und dann ja aber
wenn jetzt erwarten sind vielleicht bei
der base erbringt hat sich deine
spanischen stein spitzhacke zu machen
deswegen ist mein ding einfach ja ja die
zauberte dann in der baseball team
keinen orientierungssinn wollen wir
nicht so aufgeregt bin der aufnahme kann
komplett vergessen kann man komplett
vergessen leute ich muss das essen ich
muss das erst nicht krieg hunger schauen
sie ob ich die ganze pc nicht
aufgenommen oder ich hab noch einen
heiden hunger nach einer halbe hunger
keine weil ich kann jetzt mal ist
trocken sich hat die braun pilze nicht
nur die habe ich nicht im emmental wo
kommen wir denn her da hinten ja ok aber
jetzt mit dem bisschen hunger komme ich
noch durch das kann nicht sein
es kann doch einfach nicht sein hatte
woran die brown p 2s noch
nicht direkt aber hier oben an ich hab
dir aufgesammelt die sind dann nicht
mehr
ja oder ja die sind einfach nur so
behindert von der zahl verdeckt er in
meine fresse und ich habe wieder kanada
liegt noch eine flasche ketchup wieder
eine unlogische orientierung bist du
hier händen hier oben wenn ich wieder
auf mein gott wir haben uns da warte ich
bin durcheinander geraten welche als
neue fackeln gesetzt haben wir auf
dieses lagerfeld muss ich jetzt hier
drüben ist diese schwerer sich okay ist
nicht so schlimm lauf einfach normal ich
nehme ein bisschen erde mit coesfeld
gebraucht wo ehrlich institut schon
sagen das ist eigentlich das gute dass
ich mir meine folgen beim schneiden
locker acht miteinander angucke wegen ob
ich irgendwelche fehler welche asien
gemacht haben hier ist der gang hier
gleich noch ganz genau daran erinnern
hier kannst du mir wutentbrannt entgegen
als ich die diamanten verloren habe und
ich haben wir auch die diamanten
gefunden
das können wir nicht weg setzen
das schild können wir auch verkürzen
hier haben wir unsere ersten diaz
nämlich gefunden
ich warte ja ich bin nämlich auch gerade
wichtig ist das jetzt hier wieder zu
unserer und dann es geht hier weiterhin
ganze zeit stabile mieten
wer einmal durch drauf alles klar so
dass wir wieder absturz wo bist du einer
höhle
darum würde ich bin ich muss halt die
orientierung finden wir wirklich alles
schon gleich aussieht wir sollten jetzt
auch keine sinnlosen weiteren fackeln
setzen lasse hier anfangs tut mir egal
ja aber da war hatten wir da wir hatten
uns karotten feld angefangen
er ist es egal dass das tut man jetzt
machen die pics alle lustig man kommt
manchmal habe ich hier den hab ich ihr
ding
ich glaube dass der gang den ich damals
gebaut habe er sofort runter jawoll da
ist ein dorf oder das müsste sie jetzt
ein wenn sie das nicht ist ein
verzweifelt ich an mein orientierungs
gilt hier sind überall gänge
die dir bekannt vor die gänge
keine ahnung wie können die gänge
bekannt vorkommen egal wohin unsere pace
ja wir machen hier eine stufe tiefer
der macht mir direkt ein paar
spitzhacken erleben jetzt hier noch los
mit dem strip main ist halt echt ist es
unfassbar schwierig sich zu orientieren
leute gerade wenn man noch auf und dabei
ich suche dich gänge immer ab und
plaudern dahinten stufen brauchen wir
nicht raus
das braucht man nicht was brauchen wir
noch nicht in die gänge sind wirklich
von die gänge sind nicht von uns doch so
gekommen ist aber rüber oder bist du
spitzer körperteile dann kommen wir denn
was zum einpflanzen ist sie fragen auch
in pilzen die reichen erstmal wenn du
sagst dann den pflanzen pilze an oder
wachsen pilze schnell aber lasst
anfangsstücken jetzt kommt na ja
manchmal jetzt machen wir jetzt fix bild
habe ich dann meine mama ofen auf
unserer tiere picken hast du noch alle
bio bio logo hab ich nicht da noch eine
stein spitzhacke hier jetzt wie lange es
dauert bis ich meine steuern spielzeug
gekriegt aber das hat sich dicaprio
das war eine mutter gehen ja ich mache
mein hinten neuen in die andere richtung
dann eine strip gang an wo ich dann
striptease machst du hast du noch kohle
da kommt also bitte diese fackeln
ja ich hab nach dem start weg oder also
bis zu weit weg lassen bleibt auch
zusammenbleiben
ich wollte jetzt in genau die andere
richtung noch einen gang machen aber auf
derselben höhe
ok so einfach hier die andere aufteilung
der fackeln aber noch hier einen ganzen
sektor
am dienstag können die am 19
jetzt mache ich jetzt mal schön auf höhe
10 so wie es sein muss und ich hab die
folge bei 4 30 angefangen hast du können
minute oder so machen laut meinen teil
man sie jetzt bei 13
wenn wir ja gut dann ein bisschen drauf
legen ich war jetzt kräftig denn sowas
zu machen dauert und schilde die leute
jetzt er wärme nicht riecht nichts
richtiges zum anpflanzen was schade ist
kein weizen keinen samen müssen also von
pilz an pflanzen also ja im dunkeln
im dunkel muss man es machen aber nicht
schnell waren die dinger wachsen scheiße
langsam
natürliche höhle gefunden wenn ich
vielleicht dropped einer der zombies
irgendwas aber wir haben wenn wir jetzt
mal mädchen hätten
was machen wir dann können wir uns
gedanken machen wo wir das ganze zeug
drin brennen können
wie oft ich jetzt schon denke wie oft
wir zeug verloren haben nicht daran
zurück denke ich hätte auch wieder der
richtigen herzstillstand wir sind
irgendwie wissen vom pech geplagten
diesem projekt nicht so viel verloren
das würde genau passen wenn ich jetzt
die braun pilze wie verloren hat kann
nicht mehr wirklich nicht gefunden
vielleicht nochmal eisen und stahl und
stein
so eigentlich wie srg er mache ich
gleich wieder dann lass mir also nicht
auch noch ja mache ich ja jetzt da eine
ich habe zwei spielzeiten gemacht eine
für dich kann man nicht mehr raus
trocken da konnte mitwirken aber nicht
nee nicht mit steuerung sowie es gewöhnt
bin ja ich packe das tier da rein so
also pilze an bord haben wir jetzt
geeinigt bringt es nicht da ist eine
müsste wirklich noch mal an die
oberfläche
hast du damit 32 kann man experiment
machen jetzt mal zwei auf mich ansonsten
haben wir jetzt hier papa matthew da
drin und spitzhacke hast du ja er später
geworfen
hast du nicht auf gesammelt das sagt ein
timer ist es um es ist um es um nicht
mehr weiter aber ich habe übrigens
angefangen dieses buch was ich gefunden
buch mit wieder angefangen zu schreiben
erste tag ich fange nun an hier ich
fange nun hier an
mit unserem tagebuch das unseren
leidensweg wirklich das legend projekt
ab nun kleid dann soll
wir haben einfach ein tagebuch
betriebsrat eine wasserquelle das tape
mich so ein bisschen geld dann fangen
wir nicht so folge mit dem zweiten
tagebucheintrag an
und also während tötet bekommt ein
tagebuch und wir können auch unsere
koordinaten reinschreiben so als lustig
sein wert sind das doch kein wenn das
jemand hat von uns einer unserer
versteck finden und die ganzes jahr dann
können sie dass er mindestens holen
guck mal okay dann war es das hier
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wenn
sich gefallen lassen logisch ist uns aus
und dann mit gelb